[MUSIC - LADY ANTEBELLUM,
"ARMY"]
She can hold my dreams
right there in her pocket
and shoot down fear
with the other hand.
She's the parachute,
bulletpoof, oh.
She's the softest
place for land.
On the front line,
she's a statue,
a safe place to run
to, the strength I need
to get through every day.
So if anybody thinks I'm a hero
when they watch me walk right
into the flames,
I'm just marching
to the sound of her heartbeat.
Yeah, I'm a soldier.
But if I'm a soldier, then
she's an army, an army, an army.
Yeah, she's an army,
an army, an army.
I ain't never been one to
back down from the battle.
Yeah.
She knows that
better than anyone.
When I'm under fire, when
it's down to the wire, oh,
you know she's my loaded gun.
So if anybody thinks I'm a hero
when they watch me walk right
into the flames, well,
I'm just marching
to the sound of her heartbeat.
Yeah, I'm a soldier.
But if I'm a soldier, then
she's an army, an army, an army.
Yeah, she's an army,
an army, an army.
Oh.
On the front line,
she's a statue,
a safe place to run
to, the strength I need
to get through every day.
So if anybody thinks I'm a hero
when they watch me walk right
into the flames,
I'm just marching
to the sound of her heartbeat.
Yeah, I'm a soldier.
But if I'm a soldier, she's
an army, an army, an army.
Yeah, she's an army,
an army, an army.
Oh, she's an army,
Yeah, if I'm a soldier, yeah,
if I'm a soldier, if I was,
she's an army.
Yeah.
Yeah, she's an army.
Oh.
Come on.
I swear she saves my life.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, she saves my life.
I swear she saves my life.
[cheering]